you've probably already noticed this but
after a few false starts virtual reality
is here in a big way we have headsets
that range from smartphone power devices
like the super cheap assemble it
yourself Google cardboard to the free if
you buy a galaxy phone Samsung gear VR
to more powerful more immersive systems
that connect to a desktop PC like the
oculus rift or even the HTC 5 now what
all these have in common is that by
putting an opaque display in front of
you that presents stereoscopic 3d they
create the illusion of putting you
inside a world all 360 degrees of it
look up you see up look behind you you
see behind you but more and more some
people are convinced that VR is only
part of the puzzle and maybe not even
the most immersive one that's where
augmented reality and it's cousin mixed
reality come in where VR puts you inside
an artificial environment a R and M R
bring artifice to your natural
surroundings augmented reality can be as
simple as having a visual overlay on
your world a speedometer that displays
on your windshield say or even snapchats
face walk but when that overlay becomes
a virtual object one that you can
interact with then that becomes mixed
reality and mixed reality is what
microsoft hololens and the ultra secret
of magic leap have been working on it
can let you interact with fictional
characters in your own living room
follow the progress of a loved one or
just turn your environment into the
greatest workstation imaginable now
affordable and easy mix reality is still
a few years away it's a much more
complex and data intensive endeavor than
VR necessitating a truly insane amount
of processing but it promises to bring
about the convergence of VR and AR and
that blend of reality and illusion could
well be what our world will ultimately
look like